You gotta get over.
I'm all the way over, Brah!
Outrageous acts of science
[A] UK TV show today's episode featured our GoPro in a cannon video
so, the company sent us the cut of the episode
and also we are seeing comments on our video
That's saying that they saw the episode so we think that's super-cool
6 a.m now. Saturday, July 1st
Wendy and I are going to Minnesota, for the fourth of July
We have to leave for the airport in an hour and a half.
We haven't packed...
[distant] Wendy!
- We gotta go.
- Imma kick you in the shins.
We gotta go, we're late!
Ready to party?
Yah
Put the camera down so we can go
All right, we made it.
I left my hat back on the plane. I'm gonna go see if I can reclaim it.
Sweeeet!
I've already pulled everything out
I left my hat, Wendy left her phone. (sigh)
Let's go ahead and tell Wendy, though, that we didn't actually find it
I'll say 'yeah, they searched the whole plane couldn't find it. No-one knew where it was.'
- You're lying
- No
Is it in here?
No!
Is it.. Is it right here
You're such a jerk sometimes
Think we got everything now
Those ones with the caramel centers
And then the.. the vanilla
Cmike: Whatever you're trying to sell to me, stop selling cause I'm buying it.
Wren: Vanilla bean
Dude, you just took.. you just took
Two out of the six cookies
It's supposed to one for everyone you just took two
Mmm.
Dude, yeah, these are my favourites
Nick, Nick, take one. They're so good
That's really good!
I love it
You just automatically grabbed two
See now...
There's supposed to be one for Sam, Niko and Peter
You took two! I didn't offer you two man.
You opened the whole thing. You never offered anything.
We made it to the Lake house
This is my cousin Anne and Rob's Lake house, and it's on Balsam Lake. It's a beautiful spot.
They just redid everything so it's pretty incredible
You guys remember my brother Quinn right?
Hey!
You gotta get over
I'm all the way over, Brah!
Bro down! Bro down!
Hello darkness my old friend
I've come to talk with
Jake: Uhh, Wendy.
Wendy: Yes honey.
We made it. It's the fourth of July.
We are here at the start of the race
The marine four mile
How do you feel that your preparation is gone leading up to this event?
Preparations been great but the last couple of days has been the worst. We've been eating Taco Bell. No water, lots of beers.
Carmichael! Since, Carmichael took two of the good ones, three of you have to split the last two :(
Awwww
Took two of the good ones?
Sam: It looks like chocolate and caramel.
Niko: And what are the different types?
Y-Yeah
Did Nick, did you try it?
I did! That was amazing.
It's like a gingerbread caramel
Here, give that to someone who hasn't tried that
Everyone here, except for Peter has tried it
[Gibberish]
Yeah, she just made these yesterday
Thanks Jenna. Thanks Jenna. I don't know if Wren shows you these videos to you, but thank you.
I'm gonna.. I'm gonna...
Back of the pack club
We just want to make sure no one gets left behind you know
At a blistering pace now just past one mile
But we're not last.
I think it's all downhill so I think we're gonna make it under an hour
We're at 46-23. That's the three mile marker right there
Wendy one mile to go. Are you going to make it in under an hour?
But we got a hustle we're going to make it under an hour
Well now I think we're in last
The finish is right down there.
58:45?
Yep.
About to erupt and are moments from the finish
There's the end hunie.
[Clapping and Cheering]
You got it, that's the finish.
Wendy, how was the race?
I'm not camera-ready by any means, but feel free to skip get a sneak peek in here clip
There is there is no titty
We're back here at MSP. We've had a great trip. We did all the things we needed to do let's go back to LA
What do you mean?
[Incomprehensible, probably something about bad design]
Don't worry, it's only UK TV
What did they call us?
Epic anarchists.
That should be the name of the second channel.
Dude sick impact sounds.
So when the tail drifts out from behind the camera the extra air hitting-
dude- woah, what?
They made that, I didn't make that!
-which means it's always facing forward,
We made it to TV guys!
I-I wasn't expecting like actual commentary and stuff like that
Hey Niko.
You got long hair on your beard.
oh!
alright we gotta reshoot that, everyone act up again.
Just don't zoom in on that and no-one will notice.
Zoom on it.
yeah?